So essentially, what we're going to talk about next is how we're trying to take steps to
try to move ticlistamab and other bispecifics into the outpatient and community setting.
So basically, I think I personally, and I suspect a lot of people on this panel, think
that bispecifics represent one of and likely the most transformative therapeutic modality
that we've come up with in myeloma to date.
But community-level adoption of the bispecifics, these drugs have been approved now for
several years, and bispecific uptake in the community has been very limited by all sorts
of resource restraints.
Tara, you know, Graf talked about this yesterday.
And I think we live in a healthcare ecosystem where there's a huge risk for that inequity
to become entrenched, for this to not be a barrier that we break down without real
intentionality.
But I do think that with our current understanding of risk reduction and toxicity management,
these are treatments that fundamentally can be given in almost any community setting with
the right toolbox.
So, you know, we talked about these, we led the conference with these curves because they
are unbelievable.
You know, these are treatments that we need to get to our patients.
I would posit that accelerating community-based bispecific adoption and trying to achieve
equity and access is fundamentally the highest impact goal that the myeloma research community
can currently undertake.
That if we, that the most myeloma life years gained will be by getting these drugs to more
patients as quickly as we possibly can.
So how do we do that?
You know, Muhammad talked about some of these barriers already.
You know, the primary barriers to community-based adoption include CRS reduction.
That's the primary perceived adoption barrier.
Hospitalization, you know, many centers, you know, beyond those costs, most of our community
docs, they just don't even have a hospital to admit a patient to.
It's simply a non-starter to require hospitalization as part of the step-up process and get this
to the majority of our community sites.
And I would say that one opportunity that we often in our kind of academic research
and academic bubble don't talk about enough is the value of actually doing these trials
in community sites.
It's easy to show what you can do.
I mean, no, it's not.
It's not easy to show what you can do at the Mayo Clinic, but, you know, showing what you
can do at the Mayo Clinic, you know, immediately a community doc sees that and says, well,
that's not me.
I can't do that.
I can't operationalize what they did at MGH or MD Anderson or Mayo.
That's not me.
So, you know, we do know that one potent tool to reducing CRS risk is tocilizumab.
You know, we now have several.
You know, pieces of published data.
We have the Amsterdam data from Majestic One and Compassionate Use Tech.
We have University of Miami, which was published in Blood Advances across multiple different
bispecifics, showing that you can dramatically reduce the rate of CRS, you know, to around
10 to 15 percent in these studies with prophylactic TOSI.
These did, however, routinely involve the same observation that we would do in sort
of label, you know, hospitalization for subsequent monitoring and management.
So we.
We wanted to push it a step further.
So this is our outpatient Toclizumab or OPTEC trial.
This is a prospective phase two study that we've undertaken across our Sarah Cannon network,
primarily along with Mohammed.
And basically what we did is we incorporated in the first arm, arm a prophylactic tocilizumab
prior to first step up dosing of Toclizumab.
And then patients were treated in an outpatient setting they needed to stay close to the outpatient
setting.
They were, you know, within a we said a 30 minute radius while they were going through step up and first full dosing, they weren't allowed to drive, they needed to have caretaker support during that process, you know, between step up doses of Toclizumab, which Mohammed laid out the schedule for, you know, basically days one, four and eight, you know, patients needed to have daily check ins if those fell over the weekend, because these are the logistics that you need to figure out.
Not all the clinics have our weekend access, so patients just got a phone call or a virtual virtual check in over the weekend and then essentially.
You know, if they were sent home with a, you know, with a thermometer and a pulse ox, and they were asked to check their temperature and their oximeter twice a day.
And that was it.
That was the amount of monitoring patients had.
And this was a trial that was performed across our Sarah Cannon network in in almost exclusively what you would consider to be community routine community settings, you know, so basically many of these sites had never done any by specific therapies, you know, certainly most of them had not done any by specific startups.
So we went straight.
Into the community and had them go from the beginning of administering by specifics to doing this in an outpatient, you know, startup setting.
And so, you know, we do this is from last year's update at Soho, you know, first 24 patients, we had two CRS events.
So this is even lower than what's been described before.
I think what's happening is that we're looking less closely.
So we're picking up less, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, basically, you know, we have not had any patients who had breakthrough high grade.
So we're picking up less maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, basically, you know, we have not had any patients who had breakthrough high grade.
So we're picking up less maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, basically, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, maybe clinically insignificant CRS episodes, you know, but we're picking up less.
So we're picking up less.
Comparable to what we achieve with Tosi with something that's that's cheaper and easier to get.
So I think, you know, you know, the answer is we can definitely give by specifics in the community, you know, Tara talked about that, you know, you know, but I do think that, you know, we need to sort of develop research and dedicated tools so we can give our community docs just here is it's this is exactly how to do it to make it easy, safe in your center.
And I think that needs to be a big goal for what we're doing these days.
Okay, thanks.